ل ماذا عن الوضع وبهذا الخبر العاجل عن
سقوط شهيده وعشرات الاصابات في غارات
اسرائيليه على منزلين غرب مدينه رفح
جنوبيه قطاع
غزه نعم عبد القادر غارات جويه اسراليه
متتاليه متواصله على مدينه رفح تاخذ ايضا
منحا تصاعديا معها حيث قبل قليل قصف طيران
الحرب اسرائيل منزلين احداهما في منطقه تل
السلطان والاخر في الحي السعودي وصلت الى
هذا المشفى على الاقل شهيده وعشرات من
المصابين واصابات اخرى نقلت الى مشفى
الشهيد ابو يوسف النجار وهذه الغارات تاتي
بعد ساعات من قصف مركبه مدنيه على بعد فقط
مئات الامتار من هذا الحي في منطقه مخيم
الشابوره وغاره ايضا كانت على منزل في
منطقه حي لعوت جنوبي مدينه رفح وادت هذه
الغاره الى استشهاد عدد من الفلسطينيين
واصابه اخرين وبكل تاكين هذه الغارات تاتي
متزامنه ايضا مع غارات بين الحين والاخر
في منطقه الحدود مع مصر حيث تطال مناطق
ملاصقه
لمنطقه الجدار وغارات اخرى كانت في
المنطقه الشماليه من مدينه رفح ولاحظنا
ايضا تكثيفا للقصف المدفعي في المناطق
الشرقيه من مدينه رفح واطلاق للنار ايضا
واطلاق للقذائف من الزوارق الحربيه في
البحر هذه احداث متلاحقه متتابعه متتاليه
نلاحظ بانها تاخذ منحا تصعيديه منذ عده
ايام وفي هذا اليوم تحديدا ت زاد هذه
الوتيره وهذه الغارات بالتزامن ايضا مع
تحليق مكثف للطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه
والطائرات المسيره ما ينذر بان ربما هذه
الطائرات تقوم بمزيد من الغارات الجويه في
الساعات القادمه في ظل هذا التحليق المكثف
والمنخفض على مدينه رفح هنا جنوب قطع غزه
خمسه من الشهداء على الاقل وصلوا مشافي
مدينه رفح خلال الساعات الماضيه ومزر
طواقم الاسعاف تعمل في اماكن القصف الاخير
في حيت السلط والحي السعودي غربي مدينه
رفح جنوبي قطاع غزه هنا ايضا نرى استنفارا
للطواقم الطبيه بالتزامن مع هذه الغارات
المتواصله على مدينه رفح وخشيه ايضا من
استئناف او ارتفاع وتيره الغارات في
الساعات القادمه مع هذه الغارات الاخيره
في المناطق الغربيه ايضا في في خانيونس
المجاوره لمدينه رفح هناك في ساعات المساء
وفي ساعات النهار كانت هناك عده احداث
ميدانيه بارزه في ابرز تلك الاحداث هو
اقتحام بعض من مدارس الاواء من قبل قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي واخراج عدد من
النازحين من تلك المدارس واجبارهم قصرا
الى على النزوح الى مدينه خانيونس عبر
المنطقه الساحليه بالتزامن مع ذلك كانت
هناك اشتباكات ضاريه تدور في منطقه
الحاووز وهي منطقه تقع في الحي الشرقي
لمجمع ناصر الطبي الى جانب ذلك تنفيذ
تنفيذ عده عمليات قنص من قبل قوات
الاحتلال امام بوابه مجمع ناص صر الطبي
ادى ذلك الى استشهاد فلسطينيا واصابه عدد
اخر دا ذلك تكثيف اطلاق النار والقصف
المدفعي صوب الاحياء المحيطه لمجمع ناصر
الطبي سواء من الناحيه الشرقيه او من
الناحيه الغربيه او من الناحيه الشماليه
حيث بلوك جيل الذي بدات قوات الاحتلال
تحاول الدخول اليه وسط اشتباكات عنيفه
تقول قتب القسام انها ايضا استهدفت قوات
متحصنه عده مرات في منازله في هذا الحي
كذلك سرايا القدس قارت
بانها بالاشتراك مع كتابه القسام استهدفت
منزلا به قوات خاصه اسرائيليه في هذا الحي
كذلك قامت بتدمير جرافه في منطقه حي الامل
الى جانب ذلك تنفيذ ايضا عملي قنص في هذه
المدينه الى جانب ذلك في ساعات النهار
ايضا كانت هناك عده عمليات نسف لمنازل
سكنيه في منطقه بني سهيله وعبس الجديده
الى الشرق من مدينه خان يونس جنوب قطاع
غزه وايضا رفق ذلك قصف مدفعي واطلاق النار
من الطيران المروحي كذلك لوحظ هبوط
مروحيات اجلاء اسرائيليه في مناطق عده
شرقيه خان يونس عده مرات حسب المواطنين
وقد شاهد مواطنون ايضا اطلاق صاروخ مضاد
صوب طائره مروحيه كانت تحلق في الاجواء
الشرقيه لمدينه خان يونس ومدينه خان يونس
كانت على موعد مساء امس وفجر هذا اليوم مع
تكثيف للغارات والقصف المدفع واطلاق النار
ومحاوله ايضا الاقتراب من مجمع ناصر الطبي
و مواصله الحرا صار عليه كذلك مشفى الامل
في منطقه حي الامل الذي ما زال محاصرا
واصيب قبل ساعات من الان عدد من المرضى
برصاص قوات الاحتلال هاني الشاعر من رفح
شكرا جزيلا لك